hey everyone I'm Ilana or char Ilana Zod
welcome to my channel I'm currently in
Australia which is my first time being
home for eight months I have missed it
like absolute crazy and happened to be
in town for my aunt and uncle getting a
labrador puppy so there's a story behind
this and it's all very very very cute
my aunt and uncle loved dogs my whole
family loves dogs but they basically
dogs with their children they've been
renting a place for a really long time
now so they haven't been able to have a
dog and they basically moved out of that
place so they could get a dog they
haven't had a dog for two years and
today a puppy is arriving in their name
you're getting a cousin today are you
excited
he's going to be a white lab and he's
eight weeks old and he looks very chubby
and very cute from all the pictures that
we've seen there's already been a delay
he was supposed to arrive at 2:30
he's now arriving kind of past 7:00 so
everyone's getting kind of anxious and
worried about him and you know he's
probably been waiting for a pretty long
time at various airports because of
delays which is awful but we're also
very excited I think some people are
probably gonna cry when we see the puppy
and literally every family member that I
have in this city cluding my sister and
my grandma and my stepdad are all going
to meet the puppy at the airport so uh
super excited actually while I have you
guys I should show you how my Labrador
reacted when I got home after being away
for eight months it's super cute I'll
put that on the end of this video
because she kind of lost her mind
hello everyone I have a lot of I don't
need to do that um we are on our way to
get Tucker the eight week old Labrador
my entire family's in the car right now
it's my stepdad John that's my sister's
our mom is in the backseat Hey she's
very doc uh we're all very excited
because it's very uncommon that you meet
a puppy right because we hobbies puppies
for like two months and then suddenly
they're awkward teenagers so we're very
excited about meeting him hopefully he's
just as excited about meeting us
Oh baby we're lost we are nothing every
house you have you're fine
it's almost dead but then so taken me at
least
we're trying to find this puppy how do
you do it but we got lost we made it
he's with Qantas Freight yeah
so we're pure minutes away from eating
the puppy puppy owner seems very excited
I think she was a little stressful
anxious d2 I think what we will be
meeting in a matter of aside for me oh
no we can it's getting some more yeah in
this period well no God so we have a
puppy this is Tucker we got him out of
his cage and everyone started crying
because he's so beautiful he's quite
heavy
I think he's got beautiful big bones and
he's very soft and he smells like he's
got some heat stubborn stability good
so we met Tucker we meant to what did
everyone think of Tucker are you she's
very very I'm not gonna be home again
for three months so next time that I see
him he might be a dog
no he'll - beautiful he'll be an
adolescent he'll be in his oka teenage
back seat open Ganguly I yeah I look
forward to now Chelsea we met your
cousin he's very cute yeah
do I smell like he'll be is that what a
puppy smells like I guess my neck smells
like puppy generally bigger I think she
oh who is a little chill is that I don't
even want you to stall click idiot yeah
cheese so that's good
it's issue much we're married like the
dog timer